very curious I've had a theory as to why
the Wonder Woman release date happened
the change and I'm just curious if it
has anything to do with China it doesn't
so what can you share because originally
was coming out at a point and then I
guess it got pushed back up a number of
months we always wanted the date that we
are on right now the studio felt that
until their slate for the year before
came together and they had an amazing
end of 18 that they needed to have a big
you know what I call aircraft carrier
butter head pole in that year and they
you know we had a very rushed
pre-production because Patty also did
television TNT movie Sunday all darkened
and we had a very rushed post-production
schedule in order to make the date that
we were on which was November first
nineteen this year and you know we were
doing it because the studio said they
really needed it and then at a certain
point they came to us and they said you
know what you guys are right let's go
back to the month that you guys release
wonder what we want in and take the
extra time good